[Music]
in dangerously kinkiness submitted by
Emilio loves JK my Estevez okay
Emilio estévez Emilio you know Emilio
Estevez that sounds from I really have a
kid the blond guy the Mighty Ducks go
yeah there you go I waited I waited I
totally forgot about that movie that
sadistic teen both did after stabbing
her lover during sex
oh Jesus is he alive we can joke my
first joke is here wait the guy stabbed
with a girl stabbed by we the guys that
hurt dad
oh the girl did the stabbing was she I
mean from a doggystyle position that's
really hard to [ __ ] stab backwards
yeah it's gotta be like she's riding his
dick and [ __ ] she could have done
this shooting all fours that's true I'm
sorry
it says during sex - she could have been
blowing him and then she takes a bleed
oh you mean like this that's hard it's
doing that hard
I thought the assassin move is always
like the girl riding the guy right and
then her hairpin doubles as like a
needle that's like every like there's
always a tan and the guys like oh my god
do it better
how about spooning each one daredevil
where he was blind yes no dick not
daredevil no the one the one where it
was recently right where that chick was
Neil Patrick Harris he gone girl oh yeah
TIFF you got something right and then
you said you didn't get it right
yeah gone girl you're right we're the
chicks [ __ ] Neil Patrick Harris and
then she takes out like the the knife
and like slits his throat oh yeah so
what do you think happened was she
riding his doing like isn't not the
thing if she knows something
I want to know the details and you know
can you say it slowly okay thank you
yeah no but not sexy just like a robot
just they're calling her a young mom you
know what this is this reminded me a lot
about like I know you guys are gonna
draw a line between this crazy ass and
then me but okay what the [ __ ]
I'll tell you well why would you put
that in my mind I wasn't gonna do that
but now I have to I know it so I did it
okay so let's see how is this relation
to the girl her name is Zoe she's 19
years old I was just like tell him she's
a young mom and that's all I know I
don't know her kids there's nothing all
right that's it that's the only reason
where we were gonna draw it to you know
there's more there is more okay so um
the other thing that's similar to me so
that what she did she was trying to be
kinky with her lover Kurian who was 18
years old
Oh pillow to the face oh yeah pillow to
the face so she she won it she asked him
if she can tie him down and he said no
smart man so that's when she was like
well can I put a pillow over your face
be a kinkier and he was like all right
I'm down for that
so she went downstairs to grab a condom
and when she came back up she had duct
tape and a knife Jesus Christ and then
so she puts the pillow over his face
she ends up like running her finger down
his chest as she's writing him and she's
writing she's asking him like do you
love me and he was like what kind of
question is that
that means no what kind of question is
that
she's sending you didn't if he didn't
say dog yes what kind of question is
that that's verbatim yes what kind of
question is that
and then she says she said yes first
okay he doesn't do you really want me
and he said yes and then that's what she
said let me put the pillow on your face
trust me after he she said trust me she
ends up stabbing the Jews five times oh
this is attempted murder yeah
and then the dude says that he didn't
feel the pain from the stab wounds but
he felt the bleeding because his lung
was punctured oh I thought he didn't
feel the pain from the puncture but his
heart and emotion emotionally oh I can't
believe my own lava that like the
psychological so there were no warning
signs I mean like you know so after like
they went to court and like they pulled
up her phone and found like disturbing
images on her phone like there's like
this photo that apparently says
something like murder is like [ __ ] I
don't know you murder murder is like a
bag of chips you can't stop after once
so she killed people like a Forrest Gump
I know well I don't know if she had but
they're just pretty much saying like
based on the evidence that they had on
her phone like she was obsessed with
like murder and then so the dude ends up
taking the pill after he feels ibly the
bleeding and then look at how did he
wrestle her way it covers chest to soak
up the blood or he put me on his head to
be more relaxed well the only thing I
know after it the only thing I know
after that is that he was looking at her
she was leaning over his body not
looking at his face and just staring at
the chest and that she was holding them
she should have been a surgeon like she
was just like obsessive she needs to
turn that energy into something positive
but she wants to murder yeah she she she
wants to kill
she should have joined the military the
first rule of if you want to murder you
don't do it too close people that know
you you do randos okay cops always link
the familial and the friendship
connections that's why you got to kill
randos maybe that was her thing that got
her off though is like hurting people
she loves she's closed and maybe she
wanted to do it during sex - yeah
there's no feelings
so her what she was seeing here was that
she blacked out during the attack she
does not remember stabbing him at all
smooth cleaning insanity she said that
the reason why she attacked her was
because he was trying to kiss her and
she didn't want to because their on and
off
boyfriend I got they had sex once oh
[ __ ] you but you can't kiss yeah
something like that and so like she was
pretty much saying like she freaked out
and that it was an overreaction that she
always keeps a knife under her pillow
when I was riding his dick he tried to
kiss me
yeah so I stabbed that mother and she's
hard enough I'll believe her I mean
let's let's see let's see let's see I'll
be the judge of that by the way she got
sentenced to 11 and a half years because
the judge did not believe her he
believed she's not that she will get out
in a couple of years and she'll watch
this video she'll come after us we go
open a socket zoe is her hair real she
looks like she she looks like she
doesn't sleep much what's wrong with
this lip does he have a cigarette is he
uh is he a limey is he from the UK it
looked like you KP because he looks like
yeah yeah is that just no good a [ __ ] I
think that's how he looks right you all
dressed the same yeah that's true they
look a certain way yeah if their own if
against to the five shanks no well
that's just to really show that it
wasn't like an initial like yeah it was
like someone I said that was like a
woman I thought he was trying to she was
trying to play blood piano we're like
you got one two three four five and I
can cover each hole with one of their
things and you can lift it up and it's
like a blood like a blood guys the blood
squirts out you're so creative and you
don't like scary movies they're scary
well you just came up with I dig down
the right one wait these thoughts come
from your own mind it's not something
you you didn't see that
no is that like Hellraiser three and I
miss that one here I don't know I didn't
know you like you didn't like scary
movie I should do like scary movie I
like being scared but there's a time
with her like if I'm on the fence and
she doesn't want to watch it either I'm
not getting a good girl let's go watch
some [ __ ] let's go watch the talking
Golden Retriever movie yeah cuz I don't
like slashers slashers are weird like
there's they just don't do when you do
like psychological
yes like the shiny yes the shine oh yeah
yeah yeah shining is boring man okay I
love The Shining dude no it's cuz it's
so slow
yeah but then those last like 15 minutes
are [ __ ] insane four hours to get to
15 minutes worth it God ways that the
one where the kids looking at the TV and
it's an idea poltergeist no no no that's
a different poetry guys is the [ __ ]
no that's poltergeist that was my [ __ ]
when I was a kid are you sure it was
poltergeist yeah yeah cuz it's the house
in it with the TV and then there's that
[ __ ] old lady the warlock lady that
comes in and then she misses short one
right yeah I swear half of the movies
half of the movies at film school kids
have on their walls they don't even like
her watch you know I mean but they know
to have it on their wall so everyone's
like kid it's like having 2001 poster
yeah I was just about you can watch 2001
do 2000 want to slow like a slow in 2001
but it's like watching a little kid try
to learn how to do but how does he do
that it's that slow that's basically
slow man it's so I can like okay so you
can see but it's pretty it's very pretty
alright man what does that mean it's a
dream come true is amazed that do you
know that's like the most shallow thing
you could have said about a movie
probably yeah see there you go how smart
are you know I still like my favorite
movie Oh surprise even Private Ryan
actually that's probably like way up
there cuz it has your name on it and
it's pretty yeah I love the d-day scene
though don't everything oh man that's
real war hashas don't I like all those
see I want to be in one of those movie
so bad if I couldn't pick one part for
myself other than like being a bully in
the movie and going like hey out of my
way [ __ ] I love that [ __ ] but the other
thing the other thing is like holding
him holding it guys hand be like
I want to show I love that [ __ ] in
behalf of your bodies God and it's just
good you don't even have legs you didn't
have legs anymore I've been like Tom
Hanks like looks down and he's like
you're gonna make it I wrote this letter
at the atomic brings this letter to her
right and and like it's supposed to be a
sweet moment and she opens it and it's
just completely covered in blood like
all blood everything's blood it's all
just a bloody napkin and she's like
thank you I guess Jesus Christ and how
does it happen like Christopher Nolan's
like one of the best directors ever and
he has that [ __ ] is the true patron
dunkirk yeah yeah you got a do have all
that [ __ ] and every one of these every
single war movie hasn't seen maybe they
know that people want to see that [ __ ]
that's why right but it's the same thing
every time
for me the words every time it doesn't
part of that like the story format and
[ __ ] like every story has had like the
theme I mean like the hero's journey or
whatever like they have you thinking the
war movie thing I gotta have a dead
buddy the dying best friend a half body
dead buddy yeah buddy I think there's
nothing that speaks to Brotherhood like
someone that you can clearly tell is
gonna die in like the next 10 seconds
and you told him everything to be okay
yeah well I just love that [ __ ] I would
love to do a parody movie of that [ __ ]
let's do it well the guy's eyeballs were
out you're gonna get 20/20 vision yeah
it's like it's like he's just a [ __ ]
head and then the rest of his body is
gone and the guy of course being like
yes I'm gonna make it your blood balloon
for the one last time and you seen his
like he's like red [ __ ] girlie spine
oh Jesus
like a fish skeleton you found in the
garbage
[Music]